TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
IN RESPONSE TO THE CUPBOARD
NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC PUBLIC ACCESS
WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WITH
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTEDON OUR COMMITTEE WEB
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE
ONE ONE FOUR EIGHT ZERO. A
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES THE MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE. AND OR THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION. S. THERE'S ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT. ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE I NEEDED AND YOU ARE
NOW READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK.
YOU MUST NEW DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR
FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE MEETING. REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS NEEDED I HAVE TO SAY
THAT WE'VE NEVER I HAVE NEVER
HAD TO DO THAT IS A CARE SO I
DON'T EXPECT SO TODAY. I WANTED
TO NOTE THAT TODAY'S HEARING IS
THE FIRST POLICY COMMITTEE
COMMITTEE HEARING AND I KNEW
COMMITTEE ROOMS. IT'S EXCITING
TO KEEP KICK OFF THIS NEW ERA
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
AND WE WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE
TO THE COMMITTEES NEW HOME HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED. WE
HAVE SIX BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
WITH THREE PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
THE THREE CONSENT BILLS ARE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. FIVE AND SIX ON THE
AGENDA. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THE BILL'S LESS
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR CABALLERO HERE HOW DO
PRESENT SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN
PRESENT SENATOR DO ALSO YEAH
RUSSELL PRESIDENT SENATOR BYRD
YET HERTZBERG PRESENT SENATOR
WIENER. ONE VERY GOOD A QUORUM
HAS BEEN ESTABLISHED. NOW I'D
LIKE TO CALL OUR FIRST OFFICER
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD WELCOME
CENTER CENTER PORTANTINO YOU MAY
PRESENT YOUR BILL SB NINE THIRTY
TWO. WELCOME TO OUR NEW
COMMITTEE ROOM THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- TODAY I'M
PRESENTING SB NINE THIRTY TWO-
BILL WHICH SEEKS TO BUY BELIEVE
SAVE LIVES ON CALIFORNIA STREETS
AND ROADS. I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS IN THE
MOCK UP DISTRIBUTED MANY MEMBERS
WHICH ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE'S
COMMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS.
DESPITE DESPITE DECADES OF
RHETORIC ON THE NEED FOR SAFER
STREETS MOST CALIFORNIA STREET.
HAD GROWN MORE DANGEROUS IN
RECENT YEARS ACCORDING THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE THOUGHT NEARLY A 20%
INCREASE IN TRAFFIC FATALITIES
IN THE FIRST SIX MONTHS.
COMPARED TO THE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. SB
NINE THIRTY TWO REQUIRES A
COUNTY OR CITY TO INCLUDE IN ITS
GENERAL PLAN A MAP OF THE HIGH
INJURY NETWORK WITHIN ITS
BOUNDARIES AND FURTHER REQUIRES
A COUNTY OR CITY TO IDENTIFY
PRIORITIZE. AND IMPLEMENT SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS SOME ARGUE THAT
THESE IMPROVEMENTS ARE NOT CHEAP
TO IMPLEMENT BUT HOW CAN YOU PUT
A PRICE ON SOMEONE'S SAFETY OR A
LIGHT. EVEN WITH THAT BEING SAID
WE ARE COGNISANT OF THIS CONCERN
IT IS OUR INTENT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CREATE AN ANNUAL
GRANT PROGRAM TOWARD FINDING
TWENTY COUNTY- CITY UPON
COMPLETION OF THESE PLANTS.
THESE PLANTS THAT HAVE CALMING
MEASURES AS A FATHER OF TWO
YOUNG WOMEN AND ADVOCATES
CYCLIST MYSELF I'M SADDENED BY
THE ALL TO COMMON TRAGEDIES THAT
OCCURRED ON OUR STREETS. LIKELY
JUST LAST WEEK I WAS ALMOST
CLIPPED BY A CAR. AS I WAS
WRITING UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
THE SEEMS LIKE EVERY THERE IS AN
STORY IN THE NEWS. ABOUT A CYCLE
INJURED OR KILLED. WE KNOW
PEOPLE RUNNING TO CATCH A BUS
ALSO FACED HARM'S WAY IN MANY OF
OUR INNER CITY STREETS. BUT THIS
BILL IS NOT JUST ABOUT CYCLISTS
AS I SAID IT'S ABOUT THE SAFETY
OF EVERYONE USING OUR STREETS
SUCH AS THEIR CHILDREN WALKING
TO SCHOOL OUR PARAGRAPH.
GRANDPARENTS TRAVELING TO A
DOCTOR'S APPOINTMENT AND OUR
WORKERS CHASING A BUS. WE CAN
HELP REDUCE TRAFFIC VIOLENCE WE
CAN JUST BY HAVING. THE ABILITY
TO BE BOLD ENOUGH TO ACT TODAY.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THERE'S A
SIGNIFICANT COALITION OF- BY
GROUPS AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE. AND TODAY I HAVE
CLEARED ANG A VOLUNTEER
ADVOCATE FOR STREETS FOR ALL WE
CAN TELL YOU ABOUT HER
EXPERIENCES WITH TRAFFIC
VIOLENCE. AND I BELIEVE DAMIEN
KEVIN. IS ALSO WITH US AS WELL
FROM STREETS FOR EVERYONE SAFE.
VERY GOOD SO BOTH OF THEM ARE
GOING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. I
BELIEVE SO. IN IF SO IF WE COULD
GET- WE COULDN'T PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE AND ALLOW- THE FIRST
WITNESS COULD YOU GIVE ME YOUR
NAME AGAIN CLAIRE'S THEN.
CLOSING MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
OPEN THE LINE FOR CLOSING. ONE
OF THE CLEAR BACK. GOOD MORNING
CAN EVERYONE HEAR ME WE CAN.
GREAT THANK YOU- GOOD MORNING TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE- MY NAME IS
CLARA BANK AND I AM A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE MEMBER OF
STREETS FOR ALL. OF SB NINE
THIRTY TWO. I MUST CONSTITUENTS
PORTANTINO. SENATOR I TRAFFIC
VIOLENCE HELP IN FIFTY
CORRECTIVE NATIONALLY AND IN
CALIFORNIA IN LA SPECIFICALLY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHAT THE DEBIT
CARE THE TRAP OF VIOLENCE. IN
THE CITY AND NEARLY TWENTY YEARS
. CAN I BE UNDER. IT'S PERSONAL
TO ME I WOULD RECOMMEND BY WHEN
. OUTSIDE BUYER DRIVE THAT WAS
DRIVING AT A HIGH ALL TEXTING
AND DRIVING I HAVE BEEN A
FRACTURE OF MY RIGHT ARM UP NEXT
PACKAGE TO BALTIMORE RIGHT WITH
A FRACTURED MY LEFT ANKLE
COMMANDED PNEUMOTHORAX IN THE
KITCHEN MATIC PAINT. THE ENTRIES
THAT POSSIBILITIES. SURGERY AND
PHYSICAL THERAPY. CLEARLY NOT
IMPACTED MY QUALITY OF LIFE.
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD NOT LIVE IN
FEAR GOING OUTSIDE AND ENJOY THE
MOMENT LIVE WALKING CYCLING AND
EXERCISE OUTDOORS. SENATE BILL
NINE THIRTY TWO WITH DR STEPHEN
COUNTY EMPLOYMENT FIFTY
IMPROVEMENTS THE TECHNICAL
RESTAURANT TRAFFIC CALMING PLAN.
WILL PRODUCE CALIFORNIA LIFE
LOST INJURIES SUSTAINED THAT'S
WHAT THE PORT OF THIS IMPORTANT
BILL AND ASK FOR THE COMMITTEE
FOR SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY NOW I'D LIKE TO ASK
DAMIEN. KEVIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK. MY I. YOU NEED TO OPEN
HIS LINE AS WELL. THE LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO COMMITTEE CHAIR
THANK YOU KIND OF PORTANTINO
COMMITTEE MEMBER- CONNECTION YOU
CAN HEAR ME OKAY IS THAT RIGHT
THAT IS CORRECT. OKAY GREAT YOU
LET ME SPEAK FOR JUST A FEW
MOMENTS- MY NAME IS BEING IN
CABINET AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
AND FOUNDER OF A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION CALLED STREETS ARE
FOR EVERYONE- I STARTED THIS
ORGANIZATION AFTER MY OWN AS
WELL TRAGIC INCIDENT WHERE I
WAS- CYCLING WITH MY WIFE IN
GRIFFITHPARK A SEEMINGLY SAFE
AREA THAT HIT HIM DOWNTURN THE
CARD RACK THE QUARTER MILE FROM
THE STREET TO GRIFFITH PARK ONTO
AND DOWN THE FIVE FREEWAY
FREEWAY SPEED. RIGHT LEG WAS OFF
IN ABOUT TWO POUNDS OF FLESH IN
TWO MINUTES WELL AS BROKEN BONES
. AND AFTER FOUR MONTHS IN THE
HOT LEVIN. I WALKED OUT THE BACK
MY BICYCLE AND STARTED ON A
CAMPAIGN FOR SAFER STREETS FOR
SEVEN CALIFORNIA AND ALL OF
CALIFORNIA WORKING WITH
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE ST PAUL AND
MANY OTHER- BICYCLE AND WALK-
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE- I REPRESENT
NOT ONLY MYSELF AND MY
ORGANIZATION BUT WE- WORK WITH
HUNDREDS OF. OTHER VICTIMS OF
TRAFFIC VIOLENCE ACROSS. THE-STATE OF CALIFORNIA PRIMARILY IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHO NEED
HELP WE PROVIDE FREE HELP AND
SERVICES FOR THEM AND THEY
BECOME ADVOCATES FOR SAFER
STREETS. AND TO SAY THAT THE
ISSUE OF TRAFFIC VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA. THE PROBLEM IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT. I SENATOR
PORTANTINO BROUGHT UP THE LIVES
ARE LOST IN AND THAT IT POINT IT
IS POLITE THAT A LOT AND THOSE.
THAT ARE. ALTER AND ONE OF THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR
BILL IS. COMPLETELY THE COST BUT
LET'S LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
COST. THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE
CONTROL IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS
THE REPORT FROM THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL. MEDICAL COSTS
FOR TRAFFIC VIOLENCE IN
CALIFORNIA IT FORTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS JUST FROM TRAFFIC PILOT
. IF YOU INCLUDE THE WORK LAW IT
FIVE POINT SEVEN NINE BILLION
DOLLARS BUT IT COSTS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. A BILL YET- COSTS
FOR TRAFFIC COLLISION THAT
REALIZE THIS IS JEFF THAT IS NOT
INCLUDED. FIVE POINT EIGHT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. SO IMPLEMENT
MEASURES THAT WOULD REQUIRE
CITIES TO IMPLEMENT THEIR OWN
PLANS TO MAKE SENSIBLE PLANS TO
PREVENT THESE INJURIES- IF THE
LOGICAL THING TO DO JUST
REALIZED. IN THE TRAFFIC THE
THEORY THAT THE TECHNOLOGY OF
HOW TO MAKE THE STREETS SAFER IS
KNOWN. THANK YOU KNOW HOW TO
SAVE SOMEONE'S LIFE YOU KNOW HOW
TO- YOU KNOW SET UP A CELL PHONE
OR WE SOME OF US TO- YOU YOU
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT HELPS SAVE LIVES
ON THE STREET. AND IT'S NOT A
MYSTERY THIS IS NOT SOME
MYSTERIOUS THING HOWEVER IT DOES
REQUIRE THE POLITICAL WILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED IN THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE BACK. END BY ACTUAL
RESEARCH- THE CONCEPT MAKING
THREE SAFER FOR ALL ROAD USERS
IS SUPPORTED BY A MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIANS TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
RESEARCH POLL BY DAVID BENDER
RESEARCH FOUND THAT. 78% OF
CALIFORNIAN. THE STREETS BE MADE
SAFER FOR ALL ROAD USERS NOW
JUST CAR. AND THAT SIXTIES
PERCENT OF. WANT BETTER CYCLE
CONDITIONS SO. THAT MAKE USING A
LOT MORE PEOPLE ON BICYCLES AND
THAT WILL THIS THIS ON SEPT
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SO I CAN AND
THAT EVEN- OF A CONCERN- IN
TERMS OF THE BILL THAT ARE USING
THAT- SO I PLEASE IMPLORE ALL OF
YOU PLEASE VOTE ALL RIGHT FOR
THIS PARTICULAR BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR KEVIN FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY AND FOR SHARING
YOUR STORY AS AWFUL AS IT IS I
REALLY APPRECIATE IT- WE'RE NOT
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ANYONE THAT
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT DUE
TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRS MAY
INSTITUTE TIME LIMITS ON
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO BE DETERMINED BY THE
CHAIR ALL THESE WISHING TO
TESTIFY MET MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES I'D LIKE TO- START OFF
BY- TRYING TO TRYING. TO LET
TEST- I'M COME FROM LOCAL GUY.
AND WE LISTENED CAREFULLY. BY
THAT BUT WE DO HAVE SOME TIME
CONSTRAINTS HERE IN THIS ROOM SO
IF I COULD ASK YOU TO KEEP IT TO
ONE MINUTE I WOULD GREATLY
APPRECIATE IT- FIRST OF ALL I'D-
LIKE TO SEE IF THEY'RE ANY
WITNESSES HEARING ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. ANYBODY WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IN THE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SINGMAN THANK YOU WE
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE.
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD OPEN THE
LINE AND ALLOWS PUBLIC TESTIMONY
. IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
GERMAN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATION ONE
THE BILL AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE SOME PICTURES UP JUST ONE.
MODERATOR CAN YOU TELL ME HOW
MANY A WITNESS WE HAVE IN THE
QUEUE. IN SUPPORT. FOR AT THE
MOMENT OKAY VERY GOOD. OKAY
INSTRUCT THE PLAN IN THE- BED.
WHERE AT THE END OF. IT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PERSON
MODERATED. BACK TO THE LINE
NUMBER FIFTEEN THE ED. NUMBER OF
MILITARY OKAY. CALIFORNIA PASSED
THE LISTEN ALSO KNOWN BY AS MUCH
AS A BILL WE ARE ALSO VERY
STRONG SUPPORT AND- I. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE
. WELL NEXT TO THE LINE FOURTEEN
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING OF- MY
NAME IS MARK BROOKS OF H. AND-
I'M A PART. AND THAT COMMUNITY
LEADERS ORANGE COUNTY- THANK
WHAT THE WORK AN ADVOCATE FOR
THE STATE STREET AND I REALLY
WANT TO ADVOCATE FOR THE BILL-
ALL RIGHT- MISTER KEVIN THAT
EARLIER WE REALLY UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT THE PIETY. I THANK.
THE COMMUNITY HOW TO MAKE OUR
ROADS SAFER FOR CHILDREN HOW TO
MAKE ROADS ARE RIGHT FOR THE
ELDERLY I TO MAKE A RIGHT THEY
PROBABLY HONESTLY WE DON'T HAVE
TO DO THAT IN ORDER TO FIGHT TO
LOOK LIKE FOR THE AUTOMOBILE NOW
WE HAVE THE WITH THE MAN THAT.
WE HAVE THE POLITICAL WILL WE
HAVE THEIR HIS POLITICAL WELL
THERE IT FOR AND- I'D LOVE TO
EAT OUT BUT WE CAN ACTUALLY
IMPROVE THE PLAN A LOT OF THE
HAVE BY. AND ACTUALLY I WOULD
NEED TO MAKE- THAT HAVE ALL ROAD
USED- MANAGE THE RED PAPALIA AND
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME I REALLY ONE
OF SUPPORT FOR THE BILL STRONG
SUPPORTER THE BILL THANK YOU I
THOUGHT THEY ARE THEY GO TO WORK
THANK. YOU THANK YOU MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. THE POINT SEVENTEEN TO
AHEAD. BUT HELLO MY NAME IS
STRUCTURE. I'M A RESIDENT OF
NORTH- AND IS AN AVID PEDESTRIAN
AND NEW CAR I THAT NINE THIRTY
K. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. NEXT UNTIL HAVE NO NOTHING TO
IT THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE ON
TO- THOSE IN OPPOSITION WANT TO
CHECK IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION THAT IS PRESENT IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT
WOULD LIKE TO GIVE TESTIMONY.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING CHECK OUT
WE ARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
CHRIS WE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REGRETTABLY WITH AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
TODAY I WANT TO START OFF BY
SAYING THAT WE CLEARLY AGREED
WITH THE PRINCIPLES BEHIND THIS
BILL CITIES AND COUNTIES SUPPORT
MAKING OUR STREETS SAFER FOR ALL
ROAD USERS AND WE'RE INVESTING A
LOT OF FLEXIBLE MAINTENANCE
FUNDING INTO PROJECTS THAT NOT
ONLY FIX OUR STREETS BUT I BIKE
LANES AND PEDESTRIAN FACILITIES
MAKE EIGHTY A COMPLIANT CURB
RAMPS AND LOTS OF OTHER
IMPROVEMENTS WE'VE LISTED OUT IN
OUR OPPOSITION LETTER TODAY. THE
THOUSANDS OF PROJECTS THAT HAVE
BEEN COMPLETED WITH FLEXIBLE SB
ONE FUNDING SO WE DON'T HAVE A
PRINCE THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
BILL WE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
SPECIFICS AND THE IMPLEMENTATION
AND HOW IT'S DONE FIRST OFF
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE IDEA OF
CREATING A NEW GRANT PROGRAM
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT UNMET
FUNDING NEEDS THAT ALREADY EXIST
ON THE SYSTEM SO WE'VE OUTLINED
ABOUT TWENTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT DECADE UNMET NEEDS
FOR OUR EXISTING COMPLETE
STREETS FEATURES SIDEWALKS
PEDESTRIAN SIGNALS BIKE LANES
THINGS OF THAT NATURE. WE USED
THE EXAMPLE FROM THE STANISLAUS
COUNTY COUNCIL OF GOVERNMENTS
NON MOTORIZED TRANSPORTATION
PLAN THAT IDENTIFIES TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS WORTH
OF IMPROVEMENTS TO DO THESE TYPE
OF PROJECTS IN THEIR
JURISDICTION I DON'T THINK THAT
PLAN ACTUALLY WOULD MEET THE
VERY SPECIFIC CRITERIA IN SB
NINE THREE TWO BUT ASSUMING THAT
IT DID AND WE MULTIPLY THAT AND
SO TRIED TO GET A STATE WIDE
ESTIMATE OF WHAT THAT WOULD MEAN
THAT'S OVER SEVENTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF PROJECTS THAT
ARE NEEDED RIGHT THERE. AND SO
WE WERE LOOKING AT THIS BILL
WE'VE TOLD THE AUTHOR WE GET WE
AGREE WITH THE PRINCIPLE WE WANT
TO HAVE UPDATES TO THE
CIRCULATION ELEMENT THAT REALLY
EMBRACE SAFETY AND MULTI MELISSA
BUT THE TIME LINES IN THE BILL
AND THE SPECIFIC- IMPROVEMENTS
THAT ARE REQUIRED NEED TO BE
BASED ON A REASONABLY AVAILABLE
SOURCE OF REVENUE IT CAN'T JUST
BE FIFTEEN YEARS AND. YOU'LL DO
THIS AND SO WE BY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THAT
WE CAN A LANDINGS. THERE BUT THE
TIME FRAMES THE SPECIFICITY AND
THE NEW PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION
REALLY JUST ARE NONSTARTERS FOR
US AND SO. WE HOPE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR RESOLVE THOSE ISSUES
BUT TODAY. WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. A GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AREN'T ABLE ONCE
YOU'RE REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER- BUT ALSO JUST LIKE TO
REALLY ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY
MY COLLEAGUE AT C. SACK WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SENATOR
PORTANTINO- AGAIN REALLY DO
SUPPORT THE GOALS OF THE BILL
WANT TO JUST MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN- IMPLEMENTED AYE WHAT'S
PROVIDED FOR UNDER THE
PROVISIONS THAT WOULD BE PLACED
IN THE- CIRCULATION ELEMENT. AND
ALSO DO YOU HAVE CONCERNS OR
WHAT THE LIABILITY PROVIDED FOR
IN THE BILL BUT AGAIN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
CENTER PORTANTINO AND FOR NOW WE
ARE POSING AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. GOOD MORNING TRACY
RIGHT WITH ROCK RIBS AS A
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA. WELL THE REASON
STATED BY THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS
WHERE WE ARE ALSO OPPOSE MUST
AMENDED. VERY GOOD. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE THAT WOULD. LIKE TO TESTIFY
. IN OPPOSITION. SAYING NO ONE
ELSE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
REMOVE TO THE- MODERATED
MODERATED ARE THERE ANY
INDIVIDUALS ON THE LINE IT WAS
TO TEST AND WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. I HAVE ONE IN Q.
VERY GOOD IF YOU COULD OPEN
THOSE THAT THOSE LINES THAT
WOULD BE TERRIFIC. WITHOUT THIS
MEMBERS OF THE TEAM THAT'S ONE
THEN THE TIME- MY NUMBER. TOOK
THE HEAD. MORNING PAYMENT
CONKLIN WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. WELL WE
SUPPORT- THE GOAL OF THE BILL
I'D LIKE TO ECHO WHAT THE- THAT
HAVE BEEN OUTLINED BY MY
COLLEAGUES- THAT WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION AND- THAT AMBITIOUS TIME
FRAME SUGGESTED BY THIS BILL BUT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE DOCTOR AND SPONSORS. AND ON
THE ISSUE AGAIN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR. TESTIMONY IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE. I HAVE NO NO
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE'RE
GOING TO BRING THE MATTER BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE- I DO APOLOGIZE
THAT WE DO HAVE SOME UP PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AND I PROBABLY SHOULD
HAVE ANNOUNCED THOSE AMENDMENTS
AS WELL AS A MAJOR- CENTER
PORTANTINO THAT THESE WERE THE
AMENDMENTS WE HAD AGREED ON- ONE
IS TO LIMIT NEW CAUSE OF ACTION
TO THE LARGE NICE. LARGE THE
NINE LARGEST COUNTIES AND SAN
FRANCISCO. TO CREATE AN OFFRAMP
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT FIND
THAT FAILURE TO COMPLY WITH DUE
TO UNFORESEEN CIRCUMSTANCES
OUTSIDE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
CONTROL. GRAPHICS BILLION WE'RE
BIKE LANES AND TRAFFIC TRAFFIC
CALMING MEASURES MUST GO. OUT
MAKE IT A ONE TIME UPDATE DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION BY A YEAR AND A
HALF MADE BY. THE DATE IS JUNE.
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY FOUR AND
NINETEEN IMPLEMENTATION TIMELINE
AND LIMIT THE APPLICATION ONLY
TO THE URBANIZED AREAS- IS THAT
BUT THAT WOULD YOU UNDERSTAND
THIS TO PORTANTINO IT IS. VERY
GOOD OVER THE BILL. THERE IS A
MOTION AND AS AMENDED IS THERE
ANY ARE THERE ANY DISCUSSIONS
QUESTION TO MISTER PORTANTINO-
SENATOR NELSON WELL SENATOR NEED
THE BILL WOULD BE WELL INTENDED
BUT I WILL VIGOROUSLY OPPOSE
IT'S TAKING US BACK TO THE WHOLE
LONG TREND OF UNFUNDED MANDATES
AND UNLIMITED LIABILITY. LAWYERS
FULL EMPLOYMENT ACT THAT WILL
COST THE LOCAL TAXPAYERS DEARLY
SO I CANNOT SUPPORT THE BILL.
SENATOR GAZA THE THANK YOU
SENATOR- PORTANTINO. I DO WONDER
IF YOU COULD BE SPONSORED SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UP BY THOSE IN
OPPOSITION. INCLUDING THE
CREATION OF THE GRANT PROGRAM
AND YOU KNOW AT THE STATE THE
IT'S A MANDATE- I THINK THAT THE
BIGGEST- AS I UNDERSTAND IT AND
READING IT THIS S ONE ELEMENT
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE A DIFFERENT
OR MORE FIXED TIME FRAME. CLEAR
THAT UP I'M NOT SURE I
UNDERSTOOD IT RIGHT BUT- THAT'S
WHAT IT APPEARED APPEARED TO BE-
THE DEFENSE AND ANY OF THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT THE OPPOSITION
RAISED I WOULD APPRECIATE YEAH
ABSOLUTELY AND I APPRECIATE THE
SPIRIT OF THE OPPOSITION YOU
KNOW WE ALL WANT SAFE STREETS WE
ALL WANT- FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO
COMMUTE TO WORK. WALK TO WORK
FUNCTION IN OUR YOU KNOW.
INTENSIFIED AND MANY CITIES HAVE
HAD GOOD INTENTIONS IN THE PAST
AND HAVE ADOPTED PLANTS- BUT FOR
ONE REASON OR ANOTHER HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED. AND SO WHAT THIS
BILL IS SEEKING TO DO. IS TO ADD
CITIES UPDATED GENERAL PLAN
WHICH THEY HAVE TO DO- UNLESS
TWENTY YEAR CYCLE- TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY- CREATE. LIKE PLANS
DIFFERENT PLANTS AS PART OF THAT
PROCESS. AS YOU KNOW I MADE THE
FUNDING ELEMENT OF THIS ONE OF
MY TOP. BUDGET PRIORITIES- FOR
OUR SENATE CAUCUS BECAUSE I DO
BELIEVE- WE SHOULD PUT OUR MONEY
WHERE OUR GOOD INTENTIONS AREN'T
SO. THERE IS A CORRESPONDING
BUDGET ASK TO HELP CITIES OFFSET
THE COST OF THIS. THE OTHER
PIECE OF IT AS THE FOLKS ON THE
LINE OF TALK ABOUT WE HAVE
TECHNOLOGY WE KNOW WHAT WORKS WE
KNOW IT DOESN'T WORK WE ALSO
HAVE DATA TO SHOW WHERE IT'S
NEEDED AND SO WITH THIS BILL
SEEKS TO DO IS TO USE ALL OF
THAT DATA AND ALL OF OUR
KNOWLEDGE BOTH FROM THE
COLLECTION SIDE AND THE
ENGINEERING SIDE TO SAY LET'S IN
MAKING IMPROVEMENTS WHERE
THEY'RETHE MOST NEEDED BECAUSE
AFTER WE HAVE THE MOST FRANKLY
FATALITIES. AND SO IF YOU HAVE
THE RESOURCES IF YOU HAVE THE
PLAN IF YOU HAVE THE ENGINEERING
AND IF YOU HAVE THE TIME. AND
STILL ABOUT SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
THEN YOU'RE RESPONSIBLE SO THEY
SAID AGAIN. IF YOU HAVE THE
PLAN. THE ENGINEERING. THE DATA
AND THE TIME AND WE STILL DON'T
USE ALL OF THOSE MECHANISMS. TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM. THEN THIS
BILL IS GOING TO CREATE A
RESPONSIBILITY. I THINK WE THINK
THAT THAT WILL FRANKLY HELP.
INSPIRED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
USE THE TIME THE MONEY THE DATA
AND THE ENGINEERING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM IT'S- NUMBER AT THE END
OF THE TRAIL- AGAIN. I COME FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND YOU KNOW
WHAT I SAID LOCAL GOVERNMENT I
WOULD QUESTION SOMETIMES WHEN
SACRAMENTO WOULD REQUIRE US TO
DO THINGS UNFUNDED AGAIN THERE'S
A CORRESPONDING BUDGET REQUEST.
I WOULD SOMETIMES QUESTION
SACRAMENTO WHEN THEY WOULD PASS
THE PROBLEM ON TO US THAT THIS
IS A LOCAL PROBLEM THIS ISN'T
SACRAMENTO PASSING A PROBLEM
ONTO A LOCAL GOVERNMENT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENS ON THE
LOCAL LEVEL. IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES THEREFORE THOSE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO SOLVE IT AND
SO I THINK THIS IS A STRONG BILL
. BECAUSE IT REQUIRES. A LOT OF
TIME REQUIRES FUNDING USES
ENGINEERING AND THEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE DATA TO
UNDERSCORE SELF YES IT'S A TOUGH
BILL BUT- AS I SAID IN AS THE
FOLKS THAT TESTIFIED. IT'S TOUGH
FOR FAMILY WHEN A LOVED ONE IS
HIT BY A CAR RUSHING TO THE BUS
IT'S TOUGH FOR FAMILY WHEN THE
BREADWINNER IS. RIDING THE BIKE
TO WORK IN. IT TOOK BY CAR- AND
SO THAT'S WHY I THINK IT'S
NECESSARY SO I THINK I TOUCHED
UPON ALL THE FILMS. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH MY
FRIENDS IN THE COUNTIES AND THE
CITIES AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD AND I REALLY DO
APPRECIATE. THE INPUT FROM THE
CHAIR AND THE AMENDMENTS WE'VE
WE'VE TAKEN- BASED ON THE CHAIRS
AND PLAY AGAIN ANOTHER CHAMPION
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT. BECAUSE
WE'VE IMPROVE THIS BILL BUT KEPT
ITS FRANKLY TOUGH FRAMEWORK IN
PLACE BECAUSE THIS IS A AN ISSUE
THAT NEEDS. SOME TOUGH LOVE.
YOUR BROWSER DOES THAT ANSWER
YOUR QUESTION. YEAH I DIFFICULT
THING ONE MORE THING I SUPPORT
THE BILL OFTEN REFERRED TO KNOW.
I DO WANT THE OPPORTUNITY WHICH
I HAVE NOT. DONE SO YET IS TO
CONSULT WITH CITY IN ALLENTOWN-
SO HOPEFULLY THAT PART OF THE
CONVERSATION- IT'S FIVE A
PENDING ISSUES. THAT ARE PUT TO
THE- THANK. IF THERE ARE FURTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS SENATE
REPORT WOULD YOU LIKE THAT TO BE
A CLOSE ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D LIKE
TO ADD I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE BEEN
DRIVING AROUND SACRAMENTO- THERE
ARE SOME REALLY REALLY
IMPRESSIVE- ENGINEERING
DEDICATED BIKE LANES THROUGHOUT
THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO- AND SO
IT IT. AS IF SOMEBODY'S ON A
BIKE A FOR TWO YEARS- AS I'M OUT
THERE I LEARN MORE AND SEE MORE
AND MY OWN COMMUNITY CAN DO
BETTER THAN SACRAMENTO HAS DONE
A GREAT JOB SO. WE SHOULD
EMULATE THAT AND CONTINUE TO DO
MORE THANK YOU EXPECT THAT FROM
ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR ON THE MOTION HAS BEEN
MADE BY SENATOR HERTZBERG IT'S
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
CABALLERO. HI CABALLERO HI
SENATOR NIELSEN NIELSEN NO
SENATOR DORADOTHE RUSSELL HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI
SENATOR WIENER. THREE ONE. THE
BILL PASSES THREE TO ONE ARE WE
GOING TO PUT THINGS ON CALL FOR
SENATOR WIENER OKAY. HE SAID ON
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THINNER. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
RUNNER GENDER WHICH IS SENATOR
CORTESE SB ELEVEN. HUNDRED
WELCOME SENATOR. THANK YOU
VENTURE IN THE NUMBERS SAID
ABOUT FOR THE VERY LATE THE
PHARMACY PATRICK STADIUM THE MY
FATHER WOULD BE PROUD THAT THE
PUSH TO MEMBERS TO- PRESENT IN
THIS BUILDING AT COMMITTEE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT A TOYOTA MARKETS.
THAT HONOR SAME PATRICK'S DAY IN. WELL WHY ANYWAY. THE SHOULD
THAT HAPPEN TO THANK YOU- THANK
YOU AGAIN THE INSURER AND
CENTERS- I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT
SB ELEVEN HUNDRED TO ENSURE
ACCESSIBLE IT'S A PUBLIC
MEETINGS ACROSS CALIFORNIA IT'S
BECOME INCREASINGLY CLEAR THAT
THE MECHANISMS PROVIDED BY THE
PRODUCT DEAL WITH DISRUPTIONS
DURING BOTH ACTED PUBLIC
MEETINGS OR INSUFFICIENT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC OFFICIALS AND
PUBLIC ATTENDEES CONTINUE TO
DEAL WITH DISORDERLY CONDUCT
DURING MEANS AT SUCH A HIGH
MAGNITUDE. THE CRITICAL BUSINESS
IN THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AS A
WHOLE HAS BECOME IMPAIRED
ASSURED JUST A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES THAT SPEAK TO THE NEED
FOR SB ELEVEN HUNDRED I'M SURE
YOU'VE HEARD OF SIMILAR
INSTANCES IN YOUR OWN DISTRICTS
SAID IN ACROSS CALIFORNIA IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE LOS GATOS
MAYOR WE COULD A FAMILY AS WELL
AS OTHER MEMBERS OF THE CITY
COUNCIL ACTUALLY TELL COUNCILS
FACE DISRUPTIVE. ACTIONS
TARGETED. IN HER. THAT PUTS A
PUBLIC MEETING INCLUDING ENTIRE
L. G. B. T. THAT- API RHETORIC-
THAT'LL- TO. AND BY THE VERY
THREAT BEHAVIOR THIS YEAR. S.
THE YOUR LINDA UNIFIED SCHOOL
BOARD HAD IN MULTIPLE MEETINGS
PER WEEK. YOU TOO MANY
DISRUPTIONS IN RECENT SELLABLE
SURPRISE MEANS OF ALSO MADE
NATIONAL HEADLINES IN PART DUE
TO RACIST COMMENTS THIS WELL SO
IT'S A BALANCE OF PERSONAL
ATTACKS. BUT THAT ESSENTIALLY
DISAVOWED THE PRESIDING OFFICER
FROM CONTINUING THE MEETING WE
MUST TAKE STEPS TO CLARIFY WHAT
pBEHAVIOR SHOULD BE DEAN THIS IS
DISRUPTIVE TO ENSURE THAT THIS
DEFINITION IS ONLY USE WITH
ABSOLUTE NEUTRALITY. FOR THOSE
RARE OCCURRENCES AND PRIORITIZE
THE CITY OF OUR OFFICIALS WHO
SET A LOCAL. GOVERNMENT BODIES
WAS A PUBLIC. WE'VE HEARD FROM
MANY WILL GOVERNMENT PUBLIC FISH
AS WELL AS CAN MEMBERS THE NEW
FOR CLARITY ON THE FORTY OF
LEGISLATIVE BY CAN ACT. IN
REGARDS TO REMOVING AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO'S DISRUPTING THE
PUBLIC MEETING. OR TO THE WIDE
RANGE. OF DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
DIFFERENT INTERPRETATIONS OF
COUNCILS AND ATTORNEYS. IN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE LOCAL
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE. AS WE
HAVE AN EE SEEN MANY TROUBLING
INCIDENTS ACROSS THE STATE
INCLUDING THOSE INVOLVING
HARASSMENT THREATS OF VIOLENCE.
HAVE DEMONSTRATED THE NEED TO
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY AND PUBLIC
MEDIA ACCESS BY MODERNIZING THE
BROWN ACT. SO THAT IT PROVIDES
CLEAR STANDARDS AROUND NGUYEN
REMOVAL OF THE MEDIA PER TO SPIT
IS WARRANTED. HOW THAT HAPPENS
AND WHETHER THIRTY MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY CAN
EXERCISE. AS A COMEDIAN ALSO
STATES THE BILL THAT SETS UP A
PROCESS REQUIRING MINIMUM GROUPS
DISRUPT MEETINGS. BUT WHAT IT
DOESN'T DO IS EXPLICITLY STATE
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN. WHEN IT
INDIVIDUALS DISRUPTIVE. THE
STATE. SHOULD SET A BARE MINIMUM
IN UNIFORM STANDARDS BUT
ESTABLISHING COMMONSENSE
MECHANISMS DE ESCALATE
SIGNIFICANT DISRUPTIONS ALLOW
MEMBERS OF THE STUDENT BODY TO
RETURN TO THE IMPORTANT
GOVERNMENTAL BUSINESS IN A SWIFT
MANNER. THIS BILL WOULD HAVE
PUBLIC ACCESS TO MINUTES. SB
ELEVEN HER WILSHIRE SAFE OPEN
ACCESSIBLE PUBLIC MEANS BY
CREATING A PROCESS. TO RESTORE
ORDER. WHEN DISRUPTIONS OCCUR
PRESENT SAFEGUARDS. TO ENSURE
IMPLEMENTATION CONSISTENT WITH
THE FIRST AMENDMENT PRINCIPLES.
SB ELEVEN HUNDRED THE MODERNIZE
THE PRODUCT TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
OUR PRESENT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SYSTEMS. BY SEXUALLY
DOING THREE THINGS. FURTHER THE
- WHAT A WILLFUL INTERRUPT IS
ENSURE INDIVIDUAL. WHO IN THE-
FROM THE PUBLIC MEETING IF THE
SERBS IN OR IN FEASIBLE THE
ORDERLY BECAUSE- OF THE
CONTINUING OF THE MEDIAN THE
COURTS WITH THE LAW. SECONDLY
CLARIFYING THAT INDIVIDUAL CAN
BE REMOVED FROM THE MEETING FOR
CAUSING A WOLF THE RUSSIAN.
ESTABLISHING A WARNING SYSTEM TO
REQUIRE THAT REMOVING INDIVIDUAL
. OR INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE IN THE
pWORLD FOR ELECTION BE PRECEDED
BY A REQUEST THAT THE INDIVIDUAL
COULD TELL THE DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR. ONE NOTE THAT WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE A. C. L. U. AND
OTHERS TO CROSS AMENDMENTS TO
ENSURE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED CONSISTENT
WITH FIRST AMENDMENT PRINCIPLES.
AND HAVE EXPRESSLY STATED OR
INTENT TO PROTECT CIVIL
LIBERTIES. AND NOT TO PROHIBIT
PUBLIC CRITICISM. I HAVE
ACCEPTED BOTH OF THE PROPOSED
COMMITTEE MINUTES- THEY ARE AS I
UNDERSTAND THEM TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT IS THE PRESIDING MEMBER BUT
THE LEGISLATIVE BODY. THAT CAN
REMOVE AN INDIVIDUAL FOR
WOEFULLY INTERRUPTED THE MEETING
THAT HE GETS A VERY IMPORTANT
MOMENT. IT MAKE CLEAR THE
DISRUPTIVE INDIVIDUAL GROUP OR
GROUP HAS A REASONABLE
OPPORTUNITY TO IT HERE TO WARN
BY CEASING THE DESTRUCTIVE
BEHAVIOR. WITH ME TODAY IS MAYOR
ROB RENNIE LIVES IN THE TOWN OF
US GOT US TO SPEAK
AS WELL AS JEFFREY NEIL WEAPONS
IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES SEE SEX
. THIS BILL SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN. THE URBAN COUNTIES
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU ALL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ASK I UNDERSTAND
THAT MAYOR ROB RENNIE IS ON THE-LINE SO WE'LL START WITH THAT
MAYOR IF YOU- MODERATE IF YOU
COULD OPEN THE MAYOR'S LINE AND
ALLOW HIM TO SPEAK AT THIS POINT
THAT WOULD BE TERRIFIC. THE NET
CARE ONE OF THE- THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING SHARE AND SENATORS THAT
THE **** OUT OF MY OWN ROB
RUNNING THE TOWN OF WALKED OUT
OF IMPROVE THE APTLY SUPPORT AT
ELEVEN HUNDRED AUTHORED BY
SENATOR CORTEZ THE ALONG WITH
LOCAL OFFICE ENFORCEMENT EVAN
LOW DURING TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WHAT MAY OPERATE PERFECT.
TARGETED. INCLUDING OVER AND
YEAH L. COMMENTS THAT THE MAYOR
AND FAMILY MEDICINE PLEASE BUT
THE YEAH AND THAT'S WHAT THE
BILL TO THE POINT WHERE RESPECT
A CLEAR THE COUNCIL CHAMBER IS
DISRUPTING. THE CRITICAL BIT OF
TOWN OF THE TOWN AT OF A TO THE
WHICH LET IT AT. FORM OF PUBLIC
THE PEOPLE PLAN THAT BIGGEST
THAT LAND WOULD NOT BE. THE
TICKET GET NON PUBLIC AT THIS.
THE ABILITY EXPECTED THE LETTER
ALL. MISSION MEETING. THAT WAY
BOB OUT IS NOT ALONE REPORTS
ANOTHER BAR BUT THEY DISRUPT IN
TO COMPLETE THE WORK. THE BODY
WITH ELECT TO DO. THAT YOU HAVE
TO BE A LOT HUNDRED IT'S AN
IMPORT STEP TO ALLOW. WHY REPORT
WITH THE BROWN ACTIVE WILL.
INTERRUPTION THAT THE MINIMUM
STANDARD FOR WOMEN REMOVAL OF
THE PROJECT BUT TO THE POINT
THAT AND ARTICULATE FORTY. OF A
BUDGET BODY CONNECTED FIVE WHEN
THEY.
THAT'S EFFECTS PROCEED ORDERLY
AND RESPECTFUL FASHION THAT THE
PROPOSED MODIFICATIONS TO THE
BROWN BACK THAT SB ELEVEN
HUNDRED STRUCK ABOUT. BETWEEN
MAINTAINED INDIVIDUAL CIVIL
LIBERTIES AND POSSIBLE TO FALL
RIGHT WELL. PRODUCT THEY PROVIDE
NEEDED PUT. OF ELECTED THE
NETWORK ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITIES PIECEMEAL LOCAL
COACH AS WELL THIS AND NOT HAVE
THE- OF THE STATE BEHIND. WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT AT THAT LEVEL
TO ENSURE THAT. THEY OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WELL A MARKET
OFFICIALS WITH CAN COMPETE THE-
WORK FOR WHICH THEY WERE BACK TO
BE THANK YOU. CUSTOMER TODAY-
REMOVAL TO THIS WITH. JEFF NEAL
I UNDERSTAND IT HERE IN PERSON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY THANK YOU BUT
CABALLERO AND WELCOME TO THE
COMMITTEE. I AM JEFF NEAL WITH
CALIFORNIA'S ASSOCIATION OF-
PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS BILL AND
THE SENATOR FOR. ADDRESS THE
SIMPLE MATTER. AND BECAUSE THIS
WOULD STRAY CLARIFIED DEATH. OF
WHAT INTERRUPTION WHICH ALREADY
IN THE ACT- IT BUT IT WOULD DO
IT IN A WAY THAT WE HELP ENSURE
THAT MY AGENT HAVE THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO ENSURE SET SAFE.
AND ACCESSIBLE. FOR A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC THERE'S BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE INCREASE AT
REGRETTABLE INCREASE IN THE
NUMBER AND THE VOLUME OF THAT
DISRUPTIONS JUST OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS MALL- MANY OF
YOU ON THE COMMITTEE HAVE HAVE
HAVE SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
MAKE SOME OF THESE MEETINGS
WOULD BE UNRECOGNIZABLE TO YOU
IN THE LEVEL OF VITRIOL THAT HAS
BECOME. ALL TOO COMMON- IN THE
CURRENT LAW- IS IT IS INADEQUATE
TO DEAL WITH THE SITUATION-
SOMETIMES BECAUSE OF THE ADVICE
OF COUNSEL AS AS THE CENTER
SAID. THAT SOMETIMES BECAUSE THE
LOCAL SAFETY OFFICERS HAVE A
DIFFERENT INTERPRETATION OF THE
LAW THEN THE PRESIDING OFFICER
AND WE'VE HEARD OF CASES WHERE
THE A SAFETY OFFICER IN THE ROOM
HAS REFUSED TO EXPEL SOMEBODY-
WHEN THE PRESIDING OFFICER HAS
ORDERED IT- CITING- THEIR OWN
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW. AND
THIS WOULD. HELP TO ADDRESS THAT
SITUATION. THE BILL WILL IMPACT
. X. THE SAFETY EXCESSIVE FOR
ALL MEMBERS OF PUBLIC BECAUSE
THE KIND OF BAD BUT- THAT'S
BECOME A TOO COMMON IN THESE
SITUATIONS KEEPS. OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC AWAY- WIN AT THESE
THREATS ARE DIRECTED NOT ONLY AT
ELECTED OFFICIALS NOT ONLY IT
STAFF LIKE A PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS AND ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
BUT ALSO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WITH OPPOSING VIEWS. WHO
THEMSELVES ARE THREATENED AND
HARASSED AND BY SOME OF THE
BELLIGERENT ACTORS. M. SO SB
ELEVEN HUNDRED CREATES THAT
HELPS PROVIDE THESE IMPORTANT
TOOLS TO LOCAL OFFICIALS- THE
COMMONSENSE TOOLS AND WE HOPE
THAT- IT. DOES PASS THE
LEGISLATURE TO HELP ADDRESS THE
RISING TIDE OF HOSTILITY AND
INTIMIDATION. AT THE WE'VE SEEN
WHILE SAFEGUARDING THE PUBLIC'S
RIGHT TO SCRUTINIZE AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE MEETINGS OF
THEIR PUBLIC OFFICIALS THANK YOU. MODERATOR WOULD LIKE TO NOW
MOVE WELL LET ME ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE ELSE IN THE ROOM THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFIED YES. AT
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JEAN HURST
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE OPEN
COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT
LARGEST OF FOURTEEN COUNTIES IN
THE STATE AND AS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM AS HE'S ACT MENTIONED OF
THESE EXPERIENCES HAVE- SORT OF-
PROLIFERATED OVER THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS PARTICULARLY IN
THE STATE'S LARGEST COMMUNITIES
I WAS VERY GRATEFUL DEFENDER
CORTESE HIS STAFF AT THE ACLU
AND OTHERS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
COMING UP WITH THIS- WITH THIS
MEASURE BUT WE THINK IT IS A
MUCH NEEDED TO ASSIST. IN
RETURNING OUR PUBLIC MEETINGS AT
TWO ONES OF THE SCENES AND
HEALTHY DISCOURSE AND CIVILITY
WE ARE DRIVE HELP THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM.
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY. CINEMA ON TO
THE- PHONE LINE. MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK IF
THERE'S ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MISTER MODERATOR. ARE YOU THERE. LET'S SEE IF WE CAN GET THE
MODERATOR BACK ON THE LINE AGAIN.
CHECK IN WITH THE MODERATOR. HOW
DOES IT JUST CUT OUT BACK VERY
GOOD MISTER MODERATOR GLAD TO
HAVE YOU BACK. TECHNOLOGY IS
WONDERFUL WHEN IT WORKS. SO
WE'RE READY TO- TO INVITE THOSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. ELEVEN HUNDRED. THE
PLEASE CHECK GET ON THE LINE. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION THIS PRESS ONE
THE BILL AT THE TIME. HEY WE
DON'T HAVE ANYBODY. VERY GOOD
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THOSE
IN OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THAT WOULD. LIKE TO
TESTIFY. ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. SEEING NO MOVEMENT
WILL GO BACK TO YOU MISTER
MODERATOR AND ASK IF THERE'S
ANYBODY ON THE LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TEST A TEST BY IN
OPPOSITION ON S. B. ELEVEN
HUNDRED. IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ABOUT. PRESS ONE TO
DO THAT THIS TIME. METRO HAVE
NOTING TO AT THIS TIME VERY
GOOD- WELL MISTER TAKES A LOOK
LIKE YOU DID SUCH A PHENOMENAL
JOB AT THE FIRST HEARING THAT
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION SO
CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU BUT WE'RE
GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE CENTER HERTZBERG I'D
LIKE TO MOVE THE BILL AND ALSO
AS A POINT OF PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE- IN THIS HISTORIC
MOMENT. IN ADDITION TO THE
REFERENCE THE TIRES THIS WANT A
REFERENCE TO THE CORE ISSUE OF
THIS COMMITTEE IS THE KNOX
CORTESE HERTZBERG MEASURE. WHICH
FORMS THE FOUNDATION OF MANY OF
THE SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP CAN
COUNTIES AND CITIES AND-
COMMUNITIES OF INTEREST SO A
MAJESTIC KNOWLEDGE THE FAMILY
CONNECTION TOWARD CONTRIBUTION
THANK YOU SIR. PASSABLE VERY
GOOD- ANY OTHER COMMENTS SENATOR
GRASSO. YES- SENATE KRITISIERT
YOU COURSE- I'VE ALWAYS BEEN
STOOD UP TO MAKING SURE THAT OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS ARE
PROTECTED- THIS IS A REALLY
TOUGH TIME. WHEN THERE IS
INCREASED VIOLENCE AND HOSTILITY
AGAINST ELECTED OFFICIALS SO. I
CAN IMAGINE. THIS HAS BEEN A
VERY- DIFFICULT- ISSUE THAT YOU
ARE TAKING ON BECAUSE- WE HAVE.
SUCH INCREDIBLE RESPECT AND WE
HONOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
NONVIOLENTLY. STOOD UP AND
SOMETIMES ALLOWED MYSELF TO GET
ARRESTED- BUT NOT WITH THE
INTENTION OF HURTING AND HATING
AND- AND BECAUSE IN THAT KIND
OF- JUST THAT KIND OF
DISRUPTION. SO I JUST YOU KNOW
MAYBE YOU COULD SAY A FEW WORDS
ABOUT THAT BECAUSE- THERE ARE
THOSE OUT THERE. IN GOVERNMENT
POSITIONS. I WOULD LOVE TO USE
SOMETHING LIKE THIS TO STOP AND
WATCH ANY KIND OF OPPOSITION SO
JUST YOU KNOW WANTED TO BE A
PRIEST TALK TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT RIGHT IN IN THE IN
THE REMEMBERING THE GREAT
BATTLES OF. THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS AND- THE CONVENTIONAL
HEARINGS- YOU KNOW DECADES AGO
WHERE- TESTIMONY I WOULD
PARAPHRASE IF I MAY UM BY. THE
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS-
IN THE STATE- THIS TO THE FACT
THAT- WE HAD TO ARREST PEOPLE-
BECAUSE- OF THE WITH THINKING
ABOUT CREATING A DISTURBANCE. IN
A CLOSE BUDDY KENNEDY S. THEM TO
RECESS AND GO READ THE
CONSTITUTION UNITED STATES
PRETTY PERSON AND- SO. IS BUT
YOU WOULDN'T KNOW BECAUSE THESE
BILLS BEGIN THE DEVELOPMENT
STAGES IN OUR OFFICES- THE VERY
FIRST THING I SAID TO MY OWN
STAFF WAS WILL BE ABSOLUTELY NO
CONTENT BASED REGULATION IN THIS
BILL- NOTHING IN THIS BILL
REFERENCE. THE PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO SAY- WHAT THIS IS ABOUT IS
THE FOLKS THAT. WE SEE IT HERE
WE'LL SEE YOU AGAIN THIS IS OPEN
UP THE PEOPLE WHO COME TO THE
PODIUM. AND REFUSED TO LEAVE.
REFUSE TO ABIDE BY THE LIMITS NO
ONE ELSE CAN SPEAK- YOU KNOW
UNLESS THERE'S A RECESS OR AND
THAT'S WHAT IT CAN BE RESTORED I
THINK MOST. GOVERNMENT BODIES
ELECTED OFFICIALS AND LOCAL
COUNCILS. ARE GOOD IT DIDN'T
AFFECT WILL HAVE TO DEAL. WITH
THAT- BUT- WE PUT SOME MORE CODE
WILL SPIN IF YOU WILL THE PEOPLE
THAT WE USE IN PIPELINES. THAT
CODIFIED IN IS TO IS TO LIVE YOU
DO EXAMPLE WHICH THAT. GREAT
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE HERE THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IN. IDENTIFIED.
THE WHAT THE- OFFICER TO BE TO
MAKE THAT CALL BECAUSE SOMETIMES
YOU YOU HAVE TO DO THAT.
IMMEDIATELY WITH THE DEVIL
THIRTY DOLLARS THE CUTEST WHO.
WHO TO CALL THE POLICE. IN CAN
IMAGINE ANY OF US CAN IMAGINE
COMPLETE THE THIS WORKERS THEY-
SENATE WILL USE IT TO ONLY
STORIES ABOUT THE- THAT HAPPENS
IN THE GREAT CITY. SEPSIS OPEN
TO TIME IT TURNS TRYING TO
RESTORE WE WERE BOTH THAT
OFFICIALS- BUT HAVE APARTMENT
VOTE- AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
YOU'RE GOING TO REACH. MEDIAN
YOU KNOW WHEN SOMEBODY IS.
CHARGING THAT THE REFUSING TO
LEAVE THE CLEANER THAT- CLEAN UP
STRUCTURES INTO THE INTO THE
SPACE THAT. THIS ABOUT PEOPLE
FOR ME- SOON. OR HEARING TIMES
WHAT'S GOING ON- WOULD THIS IS
THAT IT'S NOT THE TO. US MMHM
RESPECT THAT- WE MAY NOT AGREE
WITH WHAT PEOPLE SAY BUT- THE
FIGHT FOR LIFE SAID- THE IS
ABOUT- PEOPLE WERE PURPOSELY
WILLFULLY WILLFULLY THIS THE
MEDIUM THE INTENTION. OF TO
DISRUPT THE LEADING THE WAY THAT
WOULD DISALLOW IT FROM GOING
FORWARD GOOD CONNECTED SOME WAY
OF OUR BUSINESS SO THAT'S WHAT
THIS IS ABOUT VERY FINE LINE
THERE THAT I THINK OF. A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO'VE WORKED IN
SYNTHETICALLY JOB CLEAN
COMMITTEE STEP IN MAKING SURE
THAT. THE WITH THAT THAT. MIDDLE
THANK YOU. SENATE HERTZBERG. AS
ONE OF UP ON THAT PROMOTED
BECAUSE I. THE- I THINK YOU'RE
RIGHT ENOUGH TO TAKE THIS
LIGHTLY BUT THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE YOU KNOW IN NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT WHEN OLIVER WENDELL
HOLMES WROTE THE FAMOUS CASE
ABOUT YELLING FIRE IN A CROWDED
THEATER. WE HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING
FOR A LONG TIME ABOUT THIS
DISTINCTION IN OUR CONSTITUTION.
BETWEEN ACTION AND THE RIGHT TO
SPEAK FORGET WHAT THE CONTENT
IS. AND HERE YOU'VE GIVEN THE
PERSON A REASONABLE CHANCE AND
CLEARLY YOU'RE TRYING TO CONDUCT
BUSINESS AND THE PEOPLE THAT THE
MISSILE CARE INVEST A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO TRYING TO INTERRUPT
THE DEBATE IN LOS ANGELES AND-
THAT THEY WERE JUST TRYING TO
STOP IT. IT AND DOING THAT. YOU
KNOW AND SO CERTAINLY PEOPLE
RIGHT HERE RESTED IT RIGHT TO
PROTEST IT RIGHT TO MAKE THEIR
VOICE HERE YOU'VE PUT THE A
REASONABLE BALANCE IF YOU LOOK
AT THE VARIOUS HISTORY OF THE
CASES THAT HAVE COME BEFORE THE
END STATE SUPREME COURT ON
DEALING WITH. THIS VERY
SENSITIVE ISSUE BUT CONTENT.
VERSUS ACT- I THINK YOU'VE PUT
THOSE THOSE. THOSE GUARDRAILS IN
HERE PUT QUITE ELEGANTLY. AND I
KNOW THAT THE PEOPLE OF.
CHALLENGING BUT IT'S-
RETIREMENT. TO TELL ME WE SAW
UNITED STATES CENTERS WHICH OUT
OF THE FLOOR GETTING BEAT UP
WITH CANES AND WE SEE ALL KINDS
OF THINGS HAPPEN TO OUR HISTORY
WE- TO ONLY FOCUS ON THE LAST
THIRTY SECONDS BECAUSE WE DON'T
HAVE MUCH OF HISTORICAL MEMORY.
BUT IT'S BEEN A BIG. THE BILL
CHALLENGE YOU KNOW THE IN AND
BUT- AND WINDOWS POINTER HISTORY
I THINK WHERE THIS IS THIS IS
NECESSARY ND I THINK YOU'VE
REALLY DONE ELEGANT JOB IN.
REACHING A BALANCE THAT DEALS
WITH THE IMPORTANT
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO SPEAK.
IN EVERY. WAY POSSIBLE BUT
WITHOUT. CHANGE DISRUPTING SO I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE THAT AND
THANK YOU FOR THIS BILL. SENATE
WIENER. I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
I- WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL THIS IS NOT
AN EASY ISSUE- BUT IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT I BELIEVE
IN THIS COMMITTEE- THE CHAIR AND
ARE ARE THE TWO MEMBERS WHOSERVE THE LOCAL. ELECTED OFFICE-
BEFORE COMING HERE. AND ALONG
WITH THE AUTHOR AND OF YOU KNOW
IT'S A DIFFERENT- SITUATION- AND
IN MANY WAYS IT'S GREAT YOU ARE.
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF YOUR
COMMUNITY AND IT'S VERY ON THE
GROUND AND- THAT'S INCREDIBLY
ENERGIZING AND POWERFUL- BUT IT
CAN BE EXTREMELY. INTENSE AND I
THINK LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS.
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN. VERY EXPOSED-
IN IN WAYS THAT ARE GOOD BUT
ALSO IN WAYS THAT ARE THE TIMES
UNSAFE- AND THE HOST GOT MORE
INTENSE OVER TIME. WHEN I WAS ON
THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS I REMEMBER
PARTICULAR TIME WHEN WE WERE
HAVING A VERY VERY INTENSE VOTE
ABOUT WHETHER TO REMOVE A
PARTICULAR- ELECTED OFFICIAL
FROM OFFICE. FOR MISCONDUCT. AND
WE ENDED UP NOT ACHIEVING THE
HIGH THRESHOLD WE NEEDED TO DO
THAT- BUT I REMEMBER- OF LATE AT
NIGHT I REMEMBER THINKING TO
MYSELF. IF WE REMOVE THIS PERSON
WHICH I SUPPORTED- WHICH I
SUPPORTED- BUT IF IT HAPPENS
WE'RE GONNA CHARGE THERE'S GOING. TO BE THIS CROWD IS GONNA COME
RUNNING- THE GATE AND THE- AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT ON EARTH IS
GOING TO HAPPEN IT WOULD NOT
STATE. AND SO- IT IT IS- IT IS.
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE DO THIS
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT. ENHANCING
DEMOCRACY ME VERY CLEAR YEAH ONE
PEOPLE DISRUPTING PUBLIC
MEETINGS. THAT'S NOT PROMOTING
DEMOCRACY THAT IS UNDERMINE
DEMOCRACY THE FIRST OF ALL AND
IT'S DESIGNED TO INTIMIDATE.
ELECTED OFFICIALS SO THAT THEY
DON'T THIS CHARGE THERE- AND
DON'T REPRESENT THEIR COMMUNITY
INTIMIDATION. AND IT CROWDS OUT
AND INTIMIDATE OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. WHO ARE SCARED
THEY'RE OF THE PUBLIC WHO WILL
LEAVE A MEETING. BECAUSE THEY
DON'T FEEL SAFE AND THEY DON'T
WANNA GET INTO IT WITH THE
PEOPLE. AT AND SO IT IS THIS
KIND OF BEHAVIOR HURTS DEMOCRACY
ANTI DEMOCRATIC THIS BILL
ENHANCES DEMOCRACY BY MAKING
SURE THAT EVERYONE CAN
PARTICIPATE IN A SAFE WAY. I MET
A LOT OF THAT ELECTED OFFICIALS
ARE REPRESENTING THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITY. AND NOT BEING
INTIMIDATED TO DO OTHERWISE.
VERY GOOD- YOU MAY ONE TO ADOPT
THAT IS YOUR- I JUST HAVE TO SAY
THAT I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING
THAT'S BEEN SAID AND I THINK
THE- THE IDEA OF THE CITIES
HAVING A CO DISABILITIES IS
REALLY IMPORTANT- WE DID THE
SAME THING IT IN- IN OUR CITY
AND- AND MADE IT VERY CLEAR
WITHIN THE SPORTING EVENT SO
PEOPLE WEREN'T FRIEDMAN- AND
THEY WEREN'T FREE TO CLAP AND
TO- HARASS AND- BOTHER PEOPLE
WHEN THEY CAME TO THE MIKE AND I
THINK THAT. THAT FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THE TONE THAT WE HAD- BUT
I UNDERSTAND- THAT THINGS HAVE
CHANGED AND IT'S GOTTEN MUCH
WORSE- FOR A WHOLE HOST OF
REASONS AND- I THINK THIS THIS
GIVES THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO WARN. AND THEN
TO RESPOND AND TO KEEP EVERYBODY
SAFE AS AS I SAID WHEN WHAT
THAT. I THINK WHAT WOULD CENTER
WINNERS AS QUICKLY YOU MIGHT
WANT TO PUT THAT INTENT LANGUAGE
BECAUSE IT THEN FRAMES THIS IN A
PRETTY GOOD WAY. 86% TESTICULAR
AND- I DO AGREE THAT'S EXACTLY
THE POINT. YEAH I DO AGREE. SO
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO
CONCLUDED HE DIED. AGAIN THE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THAT I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE- ROBUST
DISCUSSION HERE- AND AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE- HELP FROM THE
COMMITTEE STAFF AND- WITH THAT I
WOULD- AGAIN RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. WE DO HAVE A MOTION THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT
FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR CAMBIADO
HI CABALLERO- SENATOR NIELSEN NO
NIELSEN NO SENATOR DO ALSO ZERO
ZERO FIVE SENATOR HERTZBERG AYE
HERTZBERG HI SENATOR WIENER
WIENER- BILL PASSED BILLS OUT-
FOR TWO ONE. YES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER THREE AND THEN
AGENDA WHICHIS- BILL BY SENATOR
JONES SB THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR.
WELCOME SENATOR THANK YOU IN
HONOR OF CENTER THE TV'S OPENING
REMARKS ABOUT THE TWO TIME
AMERICANS. IN THE FIRST VISIT AS
THEY SAY. THE THIRD TIME'S A
CHARM SOMEBODY WITH IRISH
DESCENT. IS NOT PRESENTED IN THE
OUT ST PATRICK'S DAY IN THE NEW.
HEY HEARING ROOM. AT THE GO WAY
BACK TO BY MILEAGE DOES THAT BUT
IT IS BACK THAT CAN. I'VE BEEN
TOLD- MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR
AUTHORIZES THE CITY OR COUNTY TO
USE THE DESIGNATED DESIGN BUILD
CONTRACTING PROCESS FOR PROJECTS
TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL ADA
REGULATIONS CREATING EXCESSIVE
ACCESSIBILITY FOR ALL GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURES OF IS A PRACTICAL USE
OF TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND HAVING
THE FREEDOM TO USE THE DESIGN
BUILD PROCESS WILL HELP THOSE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS GO FURTHER AND
HELP PROJECTS BE COMPLETED.
FASTER SB THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR
CREATES A MORE EFFICIENT AND
AFFORDABLE WAY TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF EIGHTY ADA COMPLIANT
GOVERNMENT BUILDINGS IN
CALIFORNIA. SB I LOOK. THANKS
VERY MUCH SENATOR SO WE'RE
GONNA- FIRST ASK WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED IF
THEY'D LIKE TO TESTIFY ON THE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WE'RE ON
THE SUPPORT RIGHT NOW. SAYING
THEY DON'T KNOW WHEN MOVING WILL
MOVE ON TO THE- TELECONFERENCE
LINE MODERATOR IF YOU COULD ASK
IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTEEN FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR JOHN. AND IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY AT THIS POINT IT
IS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES.
THE AND AGAIN IT IS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. ANYONE ON THE LINE
MISTER MODERATED. WE HAVE NO
LIFE IN Q. VERY GOOD WELL WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
THEN WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE HOW
ABOUT ON THE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR IF ANYBODY ON THE LINE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THIS IS IT AND ONCE
AGAIN THE INSTRUCTIONS ARE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THE PROCESS OF
GETTING. AND THERE'S NO ONE ON
THE LINE VERY GOOD WE'RE GOING
TO BRING THE- MATTER BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY WHO HAS A QUESTION-
MOVING BILL. SENATOR NELSON
MOVES THE BILL IF THERE ANY
QUESTIONS IF NOT SENATOR JONES
YOU MAY CONCLUDE IT SHOULD HAVE
ME GO FIRST LIKE A SET THE
PRECEDENT FOR THE REST OF THE
DAY YOU COULD HAVE IN THE
FRANKLY IT'S I THINK IT'S A VERY
GOOD BILL SO I'M NOT SURE WHY
THERE'S NOT A BUNCH OF PEOPLE
RUSHING UP HERE BUT THAT'S OKAY
APPRECIATED THAT I ASKED OF IT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- THERE IS A
MOTION THE MOTION IS- BY SENATOR
NELSON TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR CAFIERO HI.
PUBLICADO FIVE SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN SENATOR DOORS. THE-
SENATORS. HERTZBERG FIVE CENTER
WIENER. WIENER- FIVE. ALL RIGHTS
FIVE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSED
. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS THANK YOU MR- CENTER JONES
FOR BEING HERE TODAY- ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB FOURTEEN NINETY-
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE AND ITEM NUMBER SIX
SB FOURTEEN NINETY TWO. THERE'S
A MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATOR
CAPITO HI CABALLERO- SENATOR
NIELSEN RIGHT NIELSEN- SENATOR
DORADO. SO SENATOR HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG- SENATOR WIENER
WIENER- THE CONTENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED- I FIVE KNOWS ZERO.
MATAMATA YES SIR BUT JUST A
PERSONAL OF MY PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE WE HAVE A TRADITION
HERE IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
RECOGNIZE THE LAST PERSON IN THE
TENANTS WITH THE CENTER LARA
AWARD- IN THIS COMMITTEE SO I
JUST WANTED TO PROBABLY PASS IT
ON TO SENATOR WINNER TODAY BUT I
THINK WE WOULD TO SHOW THE
DIFFERENCE BECAUSE OF HIS
BRILLIANCE WITH RESPECT TO
MISTER CORTESE'S BILLS MAYBE
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND START.
VENTURA MAPS OF THE AREA SO I.
ALL RIGHT YOU KNOW BECAUSE I'D
BE ON TO TAKE THAT MANTLE FROM.
SENATOR HERTZBERG HOWEVER. GIVE
THAT CENTER HEARD OF ONE AWARD A
PROCTOR. THREE HUNDRED. IN A
ROW- I THINK I MIGHT HAVE TO GET
IT MORE THAN ONE. I GET IT I GET
IT THIS IS PASSING THE MANTLE
PERMANENTLY. WELL I THINK I'LL
TAKE THAT UNDER ADVISEMENT AS I
THINK YOU MAY BE RIGHT WELL.
WE'LL SEE WHAT IT WHETHER WE
KEEP IT VERY FIRST CENTER OF ITS
BACK. WE DO HAVE A ONE ITEM THAT
IS STILL REMAINS OPEN- IT WAS
PLACED ON CALL THAT WEEKEND BUT
AND IT WAS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
S. B. NINE THIRTY ONE. PLEASE
CALL THE. ROLL AGAIN. SENATOR
WINDOWS. WIENER HI. GOOD
CONCLUDES THE VOTE AND THAT
MEASURE IS OUT FOR ICE ONE NO.
VERY GOOD I WANT TO THANK ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATE
PARTICIPATED IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WRE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE COMMITTEE OR YOU CAN
VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY. IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD THANK YOU AND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE IS A JERK.